[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh mike renner pro football focus lead
draft
analyst co-host of the two for one
drafts podcast you can head over to pro
football focus that's pff.com
use the promo code draft30 for 30 off
any pff subscription mike thanks for
joining us again we were talking about
jordan love
that you get these cryptic comments from
the packers that
hey uh aaron rodgers is our quarterback
for the foreseeable future like at some
point they have to decide
can jordan love play because you know
what are you going to do uh you don't
want to wait till he's in his like
fourth or fifth year but
if jordan love was coming out this year
where would he rank with these other
quarterbacks
i think he'd be in that second tier so
there's that top tier of five that's
probably all gonna go in the top ten and
he'd be in that second tier with
guys like kel and mom from texas a m
kyle trask from florida
and davis mills from stanford because
yeah he's talented but
man the bad that he put on tape back in
2019 like the turnovers
like people are going to make the trey
lance comparisons with him because small
school big arms athletic dudes
but he just threw the ball to the other
team far too much and trey lance did not
what's the packers strategy here man if
i knew
i would love to tell you i just i don't
know what it is i think
they thought rogers was nearing the end
they didn't think they were
as good as they were last year to be
competing for a super bowl
and thought that it was kind of a fluke
now it's you always
obviously quarterback's most valuable
position on the football field i'm not
going to knock a team
for wanting to address that but man they
had you know
he wasn't going to play on his rookie
contract if aaron rodgers plays out his
contract there which kind of just robs
you of
what everyone's looking for is that
cheap quarterback in the nfl so it
didn't really
in my opinion make sense how do you
separate fact from fiction with what the
niners are
going to do expected to do rumored to be
doing
there is no no one knows i've talked to
guys in the 49ers organization says
kyle's not talking kyle's not telling
anybody it is his decision
and he is going to be the one that makes
it so fact or fiction like
he's going to blow smoke as much as he
possibly can from now until draft day
because it does not behoove him
similar to like when the browns no one
knew who they were taking baker mayfield
until the day before
doesn't behoove him to tip his hand at
all in this situation yeah and it's it's
not similar but i thought of blake
bortles when
jacksonville surprised everybody and
took blake bortles
i think the surprise is they might take
mac jones was he worth going up to get
at number three and and and where did
pro football focus
grade mac jones yeah so if he's fifth in
the draft class for us
so obviously we would go elsewhere but
like i said the cheap quarterback is so
valuable in today's nfl
the amount of money you're saving with
the fifth or excuse me third overall
pick there compared to what they're
paying jimmy garoppolo
that's two starters you can add to your
team so the two future first rounders
they gave up
well they can go just sign two guys in
free agency with that cap space
it's not necessarily that big a deal
that they gave up those two first
rounders
but to me he's just not at the level
you're gonna have to go through aaron
rodgers in the nfc he's obviously not
the level of aaron rodgers physically
and what he can do with his arm you're
gonna have to go through a bucks defense
in the nfc that's loaded and gonna make
you throw down the football field
and that's where matt jones is obviously
the weakest like i i do think that there
are serious concerns like i would be
shooting for the fences if i'm giving up
three first-rounders to go up and get
one guy
who would you take i'd take justin
fields
from ohio state i i don't get the
massive criticism why he's falling down
boards
i don't know how many quarterbacks in
nfl history have
with his sort of ability in terms of
runs a 4-4
has a strong arm can make plays outside
the pocket and is the most accurate
quarterback in this class on throws
10-plus yards down the football field
that's a winning combination like you
can
the blitz stuff the processing stuff
yeah it's real but those things can be
fixed but what are we missing mike
because i
i had a scout tell me three weeks ago
people are over analyzing justin fields
like they
you need to simplify what you see it's
almost like we've seen too much
we like the mystery of trey lance
and maybe the mystery of mack jones if
that's possible to be an alabama
quarterback and be a mystery whereas
justin fields did this in front of us
yeah it's almost the nba draft with trey
lance like ooh what could he be well
what he is right now is probably a guy
who's not ready to play in the nfl i
think
fields is ready and like i said not a
lot of guys with his level of tools
you can't teach mack jones to run a 4-4
you can teach justin fields to get
faster and i think a lot of those
criticisms are also just ohio state's
offense
it's a downfield passing offense they
are throwing the ball deep and even when
there is blitzes like there's no hot
reads for him to get the ball out of his
hands quickly so
i do think he is being very much over
analyzed in this scenario we're talking
to
mike renner pro football focus lead
draft analyst uh
kyle pitts he's he's receiving
as much verbal bouquets as jadavian
clowney it feels like
like is it too much here i honestly
don't think it is
it's who can who can you know go over
the top the most in their praise for cow
pits at this point
and it's really is the way he moves for
a guy who's six foot five almost six six
245 pounds
those guys don't exist on nfl fields
they exist on basketball course they
exist
uh you know in other sports you just
don't see guys with his level of
movement skills and then cadets to catch
ability and he's got the biggest
wingspan ever measured
for anyone at a pro day and it's just
all these sort of things
piled together and i think you look at
why tight ends fail in the nfl
it's because they can't go out and be
cornerbacks if you just want to put
richard sherman on jason witten you know
in his prime richard sherman shut jason
witten down
so kyle pitts though you saw him go up
against top cornerbacks in college
football on the outside winning
one-on-one consistently
and that's when it's like this guy's
kind of what everyone's looking for
because he's
not going to be guarded by cornerbacks
he's going to be guarded by linebackers
and safeties and that's
a win every time what would you say to
the falcons
if they ask for some kind of advisement
strategy well one i would say hopefully
someone wants a trade lancer justin
fields who's sitting there because that
if you can get the same deal that the
dolphins got you go ahead and take that
in the heartbeat but then after that i
say you thank your lucky stars that cal
pits is sitting there because guys like
that don't get picked forth overall
fourth overall picks are usually like
dante fowler you know there's guys that
are sitting there usually number four
overall that aren't as sure a thing
as cal pits is do you like wide
receivers in the top ten
i go back and forth on this because you
can find them in the second round you
can find them in the third round i mean
dk metcalf aj brown tara mclaren in
recent years
it is possible but when a guy is as good
as in my opinion
chase from lsu you take that certainty
because it's a valuable position what
that guy brings to the table it just
changes defenses and what they have to
do to you so
yeah when you're that good i'll go ahead
and take jamar chase i saw where pro
football focus likes
the uh wide receiver i think is going to
be a steal
elijah moore he might not be a steal
though as we get closer to the draft
because he's gotten a whole lot of
publicity and you really got to go out
of your way to watch ole miss games or
something you know
and you but but he is it feels like he's
going to be
great at the next level yeah to me he's
closer to that
first tier of wide receivers that
everyone's talking about than he is to
the second tier of wide receivers he is
now five foot nine and played in the
slot and everyone's just gonna say okay
that's a slot receiver at the next level
now there's a track record for guys like
brandon cooks tyler lockett
t.y hilton who have been same size
but it's you gotta be an elite athlete
and that's elijah moore and if you go
back and look at his production
yeah he had like 500 fewer yards than
devonta smith he played five fewer games
though he only played eight games this
past season put up almost 1200 yards
was utterly dominant down the stretch
there for him and when he went and got
pressed by jc horn the south carolina
cornerback who might be the first
defense player in this draft couldn't
touch them
and that's what that's what you worry
about when guys going on the outside
instead of playing the slot
and when he got pressed in the slot no
one could touch him give me
uh your thoughts and pro football
focuses thoughts on the chief's strategy
here they've rebuilt their offensive
line
can they sustain this style
to me they're playing in all they're
playing a dangerous game
i i'm scared to what might that roster
might look like in four years
because now they're gonna have eight
guys once they sign orlando brown to
whatever
making over 14 million dollars a year by
far the most in the nfl everyone said
the rams are you know a super top heavy
team giving up all these first rounders
they only have six guys making 14
million plus a year so
you have to fill out your roster then
when you have that many guys making that
much money
you got to have cheap players and when
you don't have picks now like they're
about to not have picks for a while
they're not going to find cheap players
on rookie deals and so
i think in a few years if guys like you
know tyree kill chris jones any of those
guys they're paying a ton of money to
even travis kelsey's into his 30s now if
they start going downhill
and aren't worth that money aren't that
impact player or even they get hurt
something like that
your window is closing and you got the
best quarterback in the game you should
be going the patriots route where you
got a 20-year window
instead of just a one year window
because we see how fluky that can be
year in and year out
if you're pittsburgh are you taking a
running back
hell no and they of all people should
know
having seen what you know james connor
did in their first year there
with the good offensive line and then
seeing the offensive line go downhill
losing marcus gilbert at right tackle
losing ramon foster having alejandra
villanueva declined in his 30s
and then all of a sudden james connor
looking pedestrian they should know that
like that's the biggest driver to
success for running back is that
offensive line in front of them
and then when you have a good offensive
line it's like oh yeah that helps you in
past protection too which is what
everyone
is looking for so to me deep tackle
class would be a no-brainer to go
offensive tackle for them
how long ago were you on the bachelor
three years ago actually right now okay
so i was off by now
but three years ago during draft season
i was out there in l.a
what are you were you doing draft
coverage while you're competing on the
bachelor
so you don't have a phone when you're
out there you can't con connect with
humanity but i would be asking the
producers
because this was during free agency i'd
be like hey where did where'd josh sit
and sign you know like where'd these
guys sign
and they're like why do you care i'm
like just tell me where they stop
tell me something about the bachelor
that i i don't
see you barely get to talk to the
the girl like so becca on my season i
was there three weeks
talked to her less than an hour total
three weeks of time
i talked so like i went out there
thinking it's just you know
you're gonna get to hang out with this
girl no
not even close is alcohol always
available
so it is i was right after some like
scandal on it
to where they limit you to an hour but i
figured out a way around that where it's
like if you start going to an hour early
enough in the day
you can stockpile them and then you can
drink later in the day
how long did it take for you to make out
with becca
i never did that's why i say like within
an hour of meeting someone it just felt
weird so i never did
oh my god i know right i missed
opportunity oh
do you get do now your hair is much
shorter now but do you get people who
stop you when they see you
that women come up to you yeah i mean
yeah it used to happen a lot uh not as
much anymore though after i cut the hair
so all right
well uh they're not gonna have you back
though right
no i don't think so yeah well it's great
to talk to you mike we appreciate it
have fun this week and uh we'll check
in with you again for sure dad enjoy the
draft house that's uh mike renner pro
football focus lead draft analyst and
host of two for one drafts podcast head
over to pff.com use the promo code
draft30 get 30 off any pff
subscription